وصلت جثامين عدد من الشهداء الى مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح جراء استهداف
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لعده مناطق في
وسط قطاع غزه فجر وصباح اليوم واكتظت
ثلاجات المستشفى بجثمان الشهداء الصحفي
اشرف ابو عمره رصد لنا المشهد من
هناك في هذا الصباح هناك اعداد كبيره من
الشهداء قد وصلت الى مستشفى الشهداء
الاقصى جر غارات اسرائيليه على مدينه دير
البلح ومخيم النصيرات وسط القطاع حيث
اغارت الطائرات الحربيه لاسرا على منازل
المواطنين من
عائله جوده في منطقه الحدبه في دير البلح
بالاضافه الى منطقه البصه ايضا منزل
لعائله حموده تم انتشال اعداد من الشهداء
ووصولهم الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى بالاضافه
الى اعداد اخرى ما زالت تحت انقاذ
البنايات التي دمرتها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه بغارات جويه عنيفه الله
يرحمها ما احلى موتك يما يا باي احلاها
ادعيلي ياما اوعي تنسيني ادعيلي ياما الله
يرحمك شهيده ما شاء الله عيلته كلها شهداء
ادعيلي ياما يلي يا حبيبتي دعيلي دعيلي
الله يسرح في
وجهك
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه ايضا كان لها دور في
عمليات القصف وقصفت بشكل كبير جدا مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان وخاصه في منطقه محيط منطقه
الزوايده طواله الساعه الماضيه القذائف
المدفعيه تتساقط على منازل المواطنين في
تلك المنطقه منطقه الزوايده الى الجنوب من
مخيم المغازي مدينه دير البلح هنا حتى
ثلاجات الشهداء امتلت تماما باعداد
الشهداء وتم وضع الشهداء في ساحه المستشفى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى المستشفى الوحيد في
المحافظه الوسطى في مدينه دير
البلح